on va mettre un litre d'eau à chauffer à
chauffer dans une casserole dans lequel
on va revenir venir mettre nos trois
ingrédients qu'on a cité tout à l'heure
le savon de marseille
le savon noir et les cristaux de soude
re on va laisser chauffer le mélange le
temps que les trois ingrédients se
dissolvent se dissolvent correctement et
après il suffit juste d'attendre que ça
refroidisse pour pouvoir le mettre dans
un contenant que vous aurez choisi
on va mettre à litres d'eau dans une
casserole
on va ajouter donc 20 g de savon de
marseille
soit vous pouvez mettre les savants dans
l'eau quand l'eau est froide soit vous
pouvez mettre les avants dans l'eau en
eau est souverain et puis on termine en
ajoutant une cuillère à soupe de
cristaux de soude s'est fait à base de
créer de sel et donc ça un pouvoir
détergent également donc en fait là ce
qui est important à partir de maintenant
c'est que le savon de marseille fonde
voilà on n'est pas obligé de crier
fait attendre que ça se passe personne
une fois que le savon de marseille aura
fondu on va pouvoir couper le feu
ensuite on va attendre que la lessive
refroidissent on va attendre qu'elles
soient légèrement tiède et on va pouvoir
comme ça là m balala passé en bouteille